okay what do we want to talk about
couple things the first thing that I
want to talk about is perception
something I've become unbelievably
fascinated with recently is this binary
thing of basically and we've heard of
our whole lives half glass full half
glass empty like I've become
unbelievably fascinated with are you
sitting in this audience right now and
realizing that this is the greatest era
to be alive in the human race or or are
you consuming content that makes you
think shits terrible and [ __ ] up and
everything suck [ __ ] and it's probably
somewhere in between but for me in the
context of where I want to take my talk
which is the business opportunities the
life opportunities I think it's a
remarkable time to be alive this right
here is the remote control of our
society a lot of people don't like that
and I respect that you don't like that
when you go out everybody's on their
phones you think your kids are getting
[ __ ] up I get it but the reality of
the situation is this this device and
it's interaction on the Internet is
really a remarkable thing I am blown
away that every person in this audience
has so much more upside to achieve than
ever before strictly because of the
internet every person in this room every
person at this conference right now
including myself is grossly under
estimating the internet because we're
living through the beginning of it and
it's hard to calibrate it and realize
how big of a deal it is but the second
you start contextualizing this platform
things will start getting different
especially if you're in a place where
you've got the mindset that this is
optimism and opportunity and not just
where I'm at I basically can't wrap my
head around how easy it is
right now to garner attention and then
deploy that attention to be the governor
of Colorado sell t-shirts sell books
sell your insurance practice list us
home and sell it the bottom line is no
matter what you do here no matter what
you do here the one thing that binds all
of us is that we're all battling for
attention from somebody and then we get
the opportunity to tell them what we do
once you understand that attention is
the currency that we're all chasing then
we can start having a much smarter
conversation about this watch this and I
think a lot of people here will learn
from this how many people here and I
know a lot of you know I like I know a
lot of you follow me enough to know I
like this if you follow me but just by
show of hands and don't get lazy on me
how many people here have run Facebook
ads and it didn't work for them
raise your hands actually could we do
this again how many if you just raise
your hand everywhere I want you to stand
up stand up don't get lazy I'm gonna
give you one more second stand up if
you've run Facebook ads and they did not
work thank you thank you all right
Denver these people suck kidding kidding
kidding kidding kidding
thank you for standing up sit down
here's here's why I wanted to show you
that and here's the point I'm gonna try
to make and here's a tactical
breakthrough that I would like to
accomplish knowing Robert and Tony and
other people are speaking I think we
could talk a lot about theoretical
frameworks and motivation of mindset I
believe in that [ __ ] the most I think
optimism is the most practical strategy
in the game and I believe in that but
one of the things I wanted to fill the
void of in this schedule today is to get
you to leave with one or two practical
things that actually make an impact on
whatever that you're trying to achieve
that number one thing that I can do for
you and that practical impact is to get
you to finally understand why it is
super important that
almost 70% of this audience stood up and
that Delta is where all the opportunity
is let me explain
Facebook ads on May 29 10 on May 10th
2018 is the single best advertising
product known to man it is so grossly
underpriced that the only thing that
I've ever lived through that is similar
is early Google AdWords if I was
speaking in 2003 in 2004 about what I
was doing for my dad's business at the
time I would have asked the same
question right now the only difference
is I would have asked people to stand up
if they've run Google AdWords and it
hasn't worked for them and the same
amount of people would have stood up
meanwhile in that five to six year
period of the early days of Google
AdWords the number one advertiser on the
platform is a small company called
Amazon Amazon used Google's unbelievably
underpriced attention and to give you
guys context when I was running ads on
day one on Google for Wine Library
I was buying wine terms like the word
wine and Pinot Grigio for five and ten
cents a click those words went on to be
worth three and four and twelve dollars
a click attention much like real estate
and every other product is about supply
and demand this is the attention
platform social media is the places that
we deploy our attention within it I
believe that right now this Facebook
arbitrage is the single most coherent
thing that everybody in this audience
can take advantage of but here's the
problem if you don't know how to do it
you're not gonna get the value of the
underpriced attention a lot of people
just stood up when I made that joke
these people suck there was a little
truth in that sucky statement
it's under they actually suck it's that
their execution on that Facebook
campaign side
the ROI of any execution is predicated
on your skill the ROI of a basketball to
me is zero the ROI of a basketball for
LeBron James
is going to end up being billions of
dollars people make decisions that
things don't work because it didn't work
for them it doesn't mean that it doesn't
work I promise you and I'm making this
statement in a very selfish way so that
I'm putting it on film so I can recall
it in eight years when I'm trying to get
you to do AR or voice or AI or something
else I'm gonna point to this video
because in seven years all the articles
are gonna say this
nobody spent enough money on Facebook
during its heyday between 2013 and 2020
when the biggest companies in the world
figure out how good Facebook advertising
really is coca-cola and Coors Light and
all the biggest brands in world I'm
gonna start spending their money in the
platform which is gonna kick you guys
out of the feed because spending $8 to
get in front of a thousand people is
gonna start costing $150 to get in front
of a thousand people and more
importantly we're gonna stop converting
on those ads as much as we do now
because we're gonna be used to them and
it's always cat and mouse new
advertising comes out we convert on it
it gets mature we run away from it
excuse me for one second bro thanks for
renting the Jets shirt [ __ ] love you
the number one thing that I would like
to accomplish in this talk today is to
get every person here to go home and
Google how do I run Facebook Ads for a
concrete manufacturer how do I sell
cattle on Facebook how do I sell homes
on Facebook I want you to go home and
read or watch videos for anywhere
between seven and fifteen hours over the
next week and then spend 5 10 50 or ten
million dollars I don't know your
business or your economics but if I
compel you to this truth that I know is
real and you decide to do it the one
thing I'm scared of is you're gonna go
back home and you're gonna get your 21
year old niece to do it because she gets
that technology [ __ ] I am so tired of
people saying that they didn't grow up
with this and it's not of their
generation and that they didn't know how
to use it when it literally takes five
to seven hours of putting education time
in to figure it out to have the audacity
to say that you're 49 and you didn't
grow up with it or 64 and you didn't
grow up with it if you're still in the
game put in the [ __ ] work
I mean people running businesses and
don't have six hours to read and test
and try to figure out guys
this is called communication it's how
everything works there's a reason when
there's a coup d'etat in a country that
the first thing they do is they go after
the media company to pump propaganda
into the citizens minds comes marketing
communication if you are not relevant on
Facebook and Instagram and LinkedIn and
Twitter and YouTube right now you are
irrelevant period you don't like it
me either tough [ __ ] dick I don't care
that you missed the good old days when
the kids went outside and played they
don't do that anymore
sorry there's a ton of [ __ ] that you
don't do that your [ __ ] grandma wish
you did back in the day to holding on to
ideology and using that to run your
business is a losing formula being
romantic of how you want it to be in the
world and then not affecting your
business in the way that it actually is
is a vulnerability we are living through
the advancement of Technology technology
is not going to start stop advancing cuz
you don't like what it's doing and
meanwhile what's really happening is you
say you don't like what it's doing but
you're living it the other way there's a
bunch of hypocrisy in the system and
most importantly even if you don't use
technology because you're a [ __ ]
hippie
if you're in this audience you're trying
to figure something out right you're
trying to win you're putting in the work
this is game over because and this is
why I'm passionate about it how many
people here are retiring in the next ten
years and I don't mean you're gonna
[ __ ] crush it and buy an island I
mean you're just really [ __ ] old and
you're finished ten years show me okay
so for the 40 of you cool you could take
some of this with a grain of salt even
though I think it's relevant right now
but let me make a promise to all of you
of why this really matters the reason
you have to become great at Facebook
advertising at Instagram influencer
advertising at starting a podcast in
understanding how to do white papers on
LinkedIn not spamming and selling
branding and marketing the reason you
have to figure out this stuff the reason
you have to be comfortable with it is
technology is just starting if you think
it's crazy now where do you think this
is going did anybody watch Google's
presentation the other day yesterday did
you guys see this presentation right I
need an assistant that understands the
nuances and context of a human voice
like literally Google yesterday showed
you that anybody in the world who's an
admin or an assistant right now is out
of a job yeah
and so my question to you is if you're
not putting in the work to understand
how these social networks work how the
hell are you gonna be living in the
world that's coming next in augmented
reality and VR and AI and machine
learning and blockchain like we're not
going backwards guys like we're not
gonna all of a sudden wake up in a
couple weeks to be like you know what
[ __ ] it let's go back to farming and
[ __ ] go that way
farming is amazing bro but you're the
only [ __ ] farmer here cool and three
others I get it but guess what awesome
I'm so pumped there's [ __ ] 19 farmers
here but if this was [ __ ] 1897 we'd
all be [ __ ] farmers get it that's the
point right and the best part is when
you use technology and branding I've got
a farming friend right now he's like
[ __ ] it's getting tighter
I'm like bro instead of just selling
your crops why don't you start a brand
on Amazon and Shopify use Facebook and
Instagram and now all of a sudden your
[ __ ] peas are the [ __ ] coolest
peas on earth it's true guys this is
very simple I'm gonna say something done
I don't want to say because I don't want
to hurt your feelings that I have no I
don't know you but I do want to say this
I need you to hear this from me around
this conference it's important to me
please understand something that I'm
fascinated by and I'm hoping one person
hears me and it's the time they needed
to hear it
consuming my content coming to
conferences like this reading more books
debating about the way the world should
be being a perfectionist debating
complaining dwelling all of it excuses
for not doing if you ask me what I
really want I want this to be the last
conference you ever go to I'm being dead
[ __ ] serious I I want you to
understand that it is very likely that
if you're sitting here you are trying to
find ways not to do that's not everybody
might not even be most but even if one
person here uses reading eighty seven
[ __ ] mindset and motivation books and
listening to 44 [ __ ] podcasts and 13
[ __ ] blogs and coming to nine [ __ ]
things like this a year if even one
person here is doing that and by the way
there's a lot more than one person here
doing that it's yeah you're laughing
because you know it's [ __ ] true
cuz you know it's [ __ ] true right how
many more [ __ ] books do these people
need to read it comes down to doing you
can figure out how to market your
business to accomplish all your [ __ ]
goals in life whether it has to build a
pool in your backyard or to buy the
[ __ ] Jets whatever it is in-between
if you're actually willing to put in the
work you know what I do I [ __ ] work
15 hours a day I [ __ ] write my
captions on my Instagram I reply your
[ __ ] DMS I answer comments I read my
email it's [ __ ] work you want the
secret it's called work it's called work
and by the way do not get confused here
you have to work to match the ambition
coming out of your mouth this is not
about working 15 hours there you got
family you got other interest you do you
but don't be a [ __ ] hypocrite
don't be full of [ __ ] don't tell me
you're buying a [ __ ] private jet when
you're watching four hours of YouTube
videos a day cuz it's work you have to
figure out what you're trying to achieve
and what you want and then you need to
put in the work that maps to that
ambition and I know somebody's sitting
here and be like yeah Gary you talk
about hard work but I work smart I work
smart too and hard now what dick
this is not a debate the most
controllable thing listen we're all
we're all built differently right we've
all got different skills different
charisma levels different Beauty
different smarts we've all got different
[ __ ] but the most controllable thing in
this room the most controllable thing is
putting in the work we especially the
people in this conference including
myself look we are so fortunate we are
so entitled there is so much abundance
in the system when I see other people
try to drag people down and razz on them
for their success it makes me laugh
because they don't realize how much
abundance is in the system there's
nobody not your most direct competitor I
don't give a [ __ ] if you have a flower
shop on this side of the street and
literally on the other side of the
street there's a flower shop nobody's
taking any money out of your pocket
you're taking money out of your pocket
it's true so this is a mindset game for
me right are you on offense and realize
all this rant that I just did for four
minutes and if you do cool , let's move
on Facebook Instagram Facebook Instagram
Facebook Instagram Facebook Instagram
let me tell you why I'm saying it it's
because I'm bitter when he was talking
up here and said first of all who who
wrote my bio that was like my mom that
was long as [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I was
getting pissed I was like I was like
this guy's a dick like
um anyway when I was listening to that
bio when he was saying and he built his
dad's business from a four to sixty
million dollar business I was sitting
back there and I'm like loser and here's
why I said it I figured out Google
AdWords the day it came out I understood
that search engines were gonna be big
because the internet was crazy and
yahood already become big it was real I
understood that we would all use search
engines for a long time showing up first
for very few pennies was a good idea I
started running them day one it worked
you typed in wine wine library showed up
first
you clicked it you weren't used to it
yet they didn't even blew it out back
then you weren't even sure you were
hitting ads it was [ __ ] gangster [ __ ]
every sixth person bought something I
was paying thirty cents for new [ __ ]
customers and it's sitting in my [ __ ]
face and my business is going from three
to seven to 15 to 29 in my [ __ ] face
and what did I do
I was still doing direct mail I was
still doing TV I was still doing
billboards which was fine because it
wasn't as overpriced as it is today but
I [ __ ] hit oil and I wasn't pumping
hard enough when he said for 260 my
brain goes should have been 250 if all
the profits I was making that I was
spending on other things I put back into
Google
it would have been 250 my friends it's
not too late for Facebook advertising
and Instagram influencers it's not is it
as good as it was 36 months ago it is
not is it a hell of a lot better than
it's gonna be in 36 months it is and it
is that scale there's nothing you do it
I love that somebody's sitting here and
saying yeah but it doesn't work for my
industry [ __ ] it is for your
industry the whole country is on it
oh but Gary young kids are gone it fine
I understand
but when I run ads for 18 to 24 year
olds on Facebook we sell the living [ __ ]
out of it are they on it as much no are
they amortized out to Instagram yes this
Facebook own Instagram yes should you do
influencer marketing on its rim
because people don't know how to price
themselves if you find people at a
hundred thousand followers and you ask
them to post a picture of your thing or
tell him about your thing on DM a lot of
times they over price a lot of times
they under price you're gonna kiss some
frogs but there's a fuckload of princes
right now I'm telling you guys I'm
telling you right now take the audacity
the lack of our education the laziness
out of your system and become a
practitioner in Facebook advertising and
Instagram influencer marketing and it
will disproportionately help your
business don't know what to say and do
figure it out that's your job you want
the fruits and the benefits of winning
you got to put in the work you got to
lose some money you got to win some
money you got to read some [ __ ] you got
to try some [ __ ] but here's the thing
you'll have to spend a lot to learn you
can run a hundred dollars worth of ads
and look at what it teaches you but know
this the world is broken up into two
places when it comes to this sellers and
marketers most people are sellers so
they're gonna spend a thousand dollars
and they're gonna expect some sort of
transaction to come from it in the short
term and they're gonna deem it in not a
success the key is to understand how to
build a brand on these platforms so that
the business comes to you or there's a
halo effect a waterfall from the
marketing my personal belief over the
last two decades is to bring the most
value I always tell people don't listen
to what I'm saying watch what I do I
pump out ungodly amounts of content for
free every day I engage with my
community every day I'm not doing this
for my health or kicks and giggles I'm
doing it because I want to win a [ __ ]
Super Bowl
do you understand I believe that the
people that give the most value do you
know how weird it was when I started
Wine Library TV in 2006 I did a youtube
show for the users that don't know I
really kind of broke out in the
mid-2000s because a YouTube I started
the YouTube show and I would sit in
front of a camera drink four bottles of
wine for 20 minutes and hundreds of
thousands of people watched it it was
great anyway
I would sell these wines in my wine
store and I would sit there and I would
pan that I would drink it and say it was
light and off balanced and a piece of
[ __ ] and you shouldn't drink it wines
that I was selling from vendors who were
my partners the reason I did that was
the people in here that realized the
actual game which is in a world of the
internet where there's an abundance of
free information the people that bring
the most value to the audience win the
people who can give away the best
information for free wins for you to
give away your secrets for free you're
gonna learn two things number one there
is abundance but you're gonna learn
something else when you give away your
best advice for free 99% of people
aren't gonna do anything about it I'm
gonna sit here and I'm sitting here for
30 40 minutes pounding for people to go
home and do five hours of homework and
ten days of testing to fundamentally
unlock real growth in our business and
ninety-eight percent of you faces aren't
gonna do it that's life and there's
nothing I can do about it but it doesn't
make it any less true it's coming this
golden goose like Google was for five
years Google now is good Google's fine
Google AdWords is solid if you're good
at it and you put a lot of work into it
you can find your pockets it's nice it's
appropriately priced one more
demonstration with standing up and this
is gonna really tie the bow of why I
want you to run out of here and go start
attacking this how many people here
outside of live sports now mainly watch
oh TTS Netflix Hulu Amazon HBO prime
stand up Apple TV stand up if you now
mainly watch those I want everybody to
see this this is yeah Wow is right I
want everybody see this keep staying up
do not go down this is massively this is
the thesis of my energy of this
conversation
we can all agree that this is not a high
school or a junior high right age group
we can now agree that us older folk
watch Netflix to cool you can sit down
since ninety [ __ ] percent of you
stood up my friends ABC and NBC and CBS
are out of business as we know them
television commercial industry is 80
billion dollars eighty billion dollars
this year on making and distributing 30
and 15-second videos that are played in
between TV shows and nobody's watching
92 percent of the fortune 500 companies
in the CPG space consumer packaged goods
Cheerios Cool Whip Hellmann's this
lipstick that lipstick that cereal that
soda 90 to 33% of have declined over the
last two years why cuz they pour all
their money into commercials we've got
another 24 36 months and then the
ceiling and the floor is gonna break and
all that money is going to go into
Facebook mark my [ __ ] words you have
about 24 to 48 months to buy up real
estate of attention for whatever you do
sell hats you're a lawyer you sell
insurance I don't care what you do it is
grossly underpriced because your first
half-ass effort of a thousand dollars or
ten thousand dollars didn't work doesn't
mean it's not under priced
it means that you had their attention
but your picture or video sucked [ __ ]
and nobody watched it or did anything
about it
cool go figure out how not to suck [ __ ]
because in 36 and 40 months when all
this money comes in it will become
properly priced just like Google did and
then there may not be anything else for
us people us normal folk who don't have
eight billion dollars in money to be
able to compete for America's attention
got it
this may [ __ ] tenth where the
Internet's the middleman where the
internet is smoking out all the bad
people in our society and finally expose
thank God this May 10th right now the
Internet is the middleman and it doesn't
care that your parents were drug addicts
and it doesn't care that you got D's and
F's and it doesn't care what your
grandpappy did 40 years ago
it's agnostic it doesn't give a [ __ ] it
rewards you if you put in the right work
and do it the right way and it shits on
you if you don't do you understand if
you do that means you understand what I
understand which is this is one of the
first times in the history of the human
race where merit is being fully rewarded
and if you really really understand what
I just said it would make you get your
ass up right now run home and start
working how how you could be letting
this pass you by during this moment
baffles me once you become educated it's
one thing if you didn't see it it's one
thing if you couldn't put the pieces
together
listen Manhattan was for sale a long
time ago there's a lot of people that
decided to buy other things instead of
acres of Manhattan they missed it
Facebook was 20 bucks a share I bought
you did it there's moments please
understand this the attention of the
human race is available for underpriced
dollars if you can grab it whatever
you're up to you want to be the mayor of
your town you want to sell eight more
homes you want to build a big pizza
delivery business whatever you're up to
well disproportionately scale when you
buy underpriced attention and you get
people to know what you're up to and
what you do and what value bring this is
special this is a magical era and you
will regret it if you don't deploy all
of your efforts against it and so while
you debate that it's not for your
industry
well you sit around and what think about
what other people are gonna think about
you if you make that content or if the
Lighting's good or you don't like your
left side of your [ __ ] face or
whatever the [ __ ] you think while you do
all that debating people are grabbing up
this opportunity I highly recommend my
friends for you to become a practitioner
not a headline reader of the current
state of the internet it's called social
networks on the cell phone it's also
called podcasts on podcast networks its
vlogging on YouTube it's writing
long-form articles on LinkedIn and maybe
your industry is boring by your
standards but it's still your industry
and if you could be the queen or king of
your industry that you win and the way
to do that in 2018 is to be a person
that knows how to make pictures videos
audio clips and written words on seven
platforms it's simple if my friends I am
NOT a big time genius I'm simple I care
about one thing your attention your ears
and your eyes are my religion I watch
where you go I watch you saying you're
not gonna go there
you know me people here said they would
never be on Instagram and now are
anybody people here when they got the
first emoji said what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ]
who now send poop emojis 24 hours a day
some of the older cats in here said they
would never get a cell phone because
their [ __ ] pager was good enough the
cats out of the bag we're not going back
and you need to understand that social
norms are changing online dating twelve
years ago weird and creepy today the
establishment could you imagine if I
stood up here eight years ago and said
in eight years all the parents of this
room are gonna want their children to go
into a stranger's car cuz they're gonna
think that's safer than them driving
themselves
do you know that all across America
right now if you have enough net worth
if you're rich that the big gift for a
16 or 17 year old is unlimited
uber not a new car they want their 16
year old daughter at 11 o'clock at night
to go into a stranger's car every day of
the week I would have been laughed
offstage if I would have pitched you
that idea 10 years ago
social norms are breaking in front of
our eyes the Internet is the biggest
invention in the human race it is it's
changed everything and it's going to
change everything and so I implore you
to be so grateful that you're actually
navigating through this time of
abundance so you're more than welcome to
watch two or three antiquated news
stations who tell you the world suck
[ __ ] or you can watch what's actually
happening which is this is the greatest
[ __ ] era to ever be alive people are
living longer healthier better and
there's nothing but opportunity and
nobody can stop you except your lack of
education or your entitlement or being
[ __ ] lazy stop
[Applause]
my friends the current scientifical
mathematical odds of being born are 400
trillion to one like your your mom might
have got up and got another glass of
wine
400 trillion to one you're more likely
to win the Mega Millions nine times in
your life than you are to even have a
life I like data that's data we've got
one life do something about it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you giver the hand
Gary Vaynerchuk killed my hand under
thank you thank you Denver Gary Vee